all right um a
[Music]
little review of the back brake ball I
think we have a couple videos on it but
give go over it again maybe we'll get
better camera angles on it and then give
you some context for it
okay
um the fall is going to utilize the same
kazushi patterns only towards the rear
so you have a back outward and a back
inward kazushi pattern uh it's going to
follow the same
rules of the x pattern going forward so
the extremities of the body whatever
that might be but usually it's the head
and the feet they will go in different
directions on the spiral and the center
of gravity will go in a third different
direction ction uh so that posture is
entirely
deconstructed um that's not going to
change something that comes up in the
back
breakfall is uh that we I want to touch
upon here a little bit is that you still
have your Tactical priorities so the
Tactical priorities of uh
extraction and then weapon deployment
those
override uh whatever else you're going
to do and this is very unique to iido
throws um I don't want to say they're
iido throws but mid-range grappling okay
Judo to me is close range grappling um
and and Judo did have mid-range
grappling and in that sense it's just
like iido okay um but something
particular to mid-range grappling is
that you try to throw them outside of
weapon retention issue that's usually
about 4 feet okay um so they shouldn't
touch the ground until they're 4T away
from you meaning you should not all
things being equal throw them underneath
you okay because if you throw them
underneath you you're in weapon
retention issue range um and that's not
good or they can grab you and you can't
extract yourself from the engagement
okay so it's very important that we
understand that in nag waza whether it's
forward or backwards uh UK should not
touch the ground in any way until about
4et from where you're
at um another Factor should come in for
why you're throwing them directly under
you okay
uh one like I can't I can't throw them
4T away from
me or two the terrain doesn't allow for
it um or I already have my weapon out so
if I have my weapon out and I throw them
underneath me I can use that weapon uh
if you are for whatever reason opting
for or forced to opt for them being
thrown under you and you don't have a
weapon you have to use your body weapons
so so that would be your kicks and your
Stomps that just goes right into that
okay um but nobody lands underneath you
with you not doing anything that's just
crazy
okay
um if we look
at the nag UK relationship we know that
it's a three-dimensional spiral through
space it's not going to change whether
that's going forward or backwards
okay um we also
know
that the same line through here which
establishes that index line uh that is
what's going to Mark where you use your
x pattern however it is whether it's
inward or outward okay that doesn't
change
um because of this if we look look a
certain
way we also know that the style of ukami
or the receptiveness of the ukemi it has
to fit the actual throwing
geometry so because we're using that
spiral on a x where in the end the
extremities of the posture the head or
the foot and the foot and the line of
gravity the center of gravity they are
all thrown on different vectors of that
spiral um we know
that the head's going to go One
Direction the feet are going to go
another Direction and the center's going
to go another direction we know that we
are not going to have all three things
go in a single Direction which is very
very common uh when you watch everybody
else's back break fall um or sometimes
substitutable with the uh what is it
called the backwards roll backwards
roll um the NOG is always throwing on
this
line and so someone can I'll demonstrate
the back breakfall that works on this
line or the backwards roll which we
don't even do we don't do the backwards
roll we don't train in the backwards r
roll um if I were to tell uh even Ronin
do a backwards roll uh you'd be shocked
that he can't do it he would look like
the biggest idiot okay because we don't
do it we don't do it because this is
never the throwing architecture first
and foremost you won't be able to do a
backwards roll uh with our throwing
architecture and also uh it's just not
good Zan Shin because sooner or later
later you're going to be looking down
you're going to break eye contact with
the Nugget that's always wrong you're
going to be looking the other way it's
also why we don't
do
um the um Donovan weight lineage of
ukami they always looking the wrong way
with the back of the head facing the net
that's just a no no uh all that is
incorrect uh but ultimately you won't be
able to take any ukemi that is trying to
be on a single line that's not going to
happen that's just going to make sure
you crash harder when you try to do that
all right the last thing we have to go
into in the um back
breakfall is because UK always has a
spinal
displacement to our throwing
architectures um and because we cannot
contest and do a Yin y or y y Clash
there because you can't do those things
uh even though UK is
going backwards in air quotes here the
center of gravity must be going forward
must be going forward must be going this
way and we deal with this contestation
by turning this like we always do so ukz
is going to do something like this on
the back outward and something like this
on the back inward breakfall okay but
there's always a forward inertia to UK
it that's always going to have the
center up Center is going to be made to
go up the center is not going to go
backwards or down which is what everyone
does who tries to stay on a single line
whether they do the back break fall or
the backwards roll you cannot do a
backwards roll unless your Center goes
backwards and down but we're not going
to let it go backwards and down first
per prescription you must finally
displace and then secondly we're going
to I seiz your Center to continue it
going forward you cannot do a backwards
roll or the straight line back back
breakfall which I'll demonstrate
now you can say stand we we'll use this
line I don't know which line do you
think you can see the best on the map
through the camera this one okay so here
we have this line on the mat made
between the
tongue and uh it's very common that
people want to do some Judo variant in
my opinion and it probably works on the
on the throw where you throw people
under you um but we just don't do it so
uh either your feet remain in place and
you kind of squat down and your
back goes back they teach this at the
Law Enforcement Academy it makes me
cringe all the time so the idea is I'll
do it from the side
maybe this to show what we're talking
about is they either SWA down back was
back and they come back up or what have
you or go into the
fact sometimes there's a single
foot and uh very common that they go
down we do the two common things so they
might take a single foot back and they
might go on that heel but a lot of times
they use the in step and they go back
again and they do the same thing but if
you pay pay
attention if that was my angle of attack
as Naga I'm throwing on this
line my
head is on the line of attack as you can
so I got pushed this way and I would
fall and my head is on the line of
attack and the only thing that stopped
me is my slapping which you can't do in
the street hurts like f and uh my
abdominal strength basically the only
thing stopping me from hitting my head
is a y Yong Clash against the throwing
architecture
so
um
usually if she has a throwing
architecture just
relax um and she's working on that line
she enters and there's the throw and
then I get accelerated on the line and
then I do that maneuver
okay that's not going to
happen if you look at certain
things her throw is just an acceleration
rearward so
I'm not going to fight
her we will deal with that next but as
she goes like really fast you can go
fast and hard fast and
hard there was no reason why I couldn't
run out of
that which is what actually
most this is right you you accelerate
Tristan Bakers and he's going to do that
all day to you you right he doesn't know
any better but a lot of people in the
fedorite world they don't know better
they don't they don't realize that's
just not going to happen Okay so we have
to do things
differently so that they can't do
that and what allows me to do
that as she goes backwards is that
instead of being a good choreograph you
and doing that I just keep my hip
relationship and I'm
out I have I have control whether I give
up my hip or whether I
don't well that's not a CI I I don't
seek control
okay whether I did that I had control or
whether I do this I have control that's
not a Cy but in that that that's where
you see somebody that can squat down
they bring their hips down and then they
Squat and they do the backwards roll or
the break
ball we're not going to do that okay so
we have some
things we know I'm never going to throw
back on that line cuz she can just walk
back out of
it we also
know that even her on the same
line because I just push it into that
back
foot she can be very
strong and not going to get it okay that
takes too long that's already not
tactical this just
okay so we have to have the hips go
forward
the hips have to go forward I don't want
to push her back onto her other foot
this way then she got her hips
back so the hips go forward I bring her
around and I now bring her this
way hips go
forward I bring her around and I go this
way
in which case you can see she's not on
the line she's never going to be on the
line okay and of course it won't do it
to her but when all that's happening
when her body is going forward and then
being
turned and then being brought this
way we have the X
power okay so her body's coming forward
hits
up she's going to go this way and that's
where boom we hit that bottom leg so
it's on this
leg I'm going to hold her energy going
on this way and that's where I boom hit
that leg
okay and there's no way I don't you just
try to figure it out just go straight
down
see how her butt has to lower and then
she goes back and there she does that
there's just absolutely no way she could
do that do you guys get that there's no
way okay um so she can't do the
backwards roll either her hips can't go
back they're not going to be on a
straight line and you ain't lowering
okay make make sense okay so we
have to learn this other
rle um and that other
role is also makes sense that even if
you could do that other thing it doesn't
makes sense that you leave your target
the head which is the
target of a throw to the back back of
the head is the Target that you would
leave your head on the line of attack
that makes no sense you're supposed to
be doing a non-c contesting art how does
that make sense but it's everywhere Okay
so let us get a curved pattern versus a
straight pattern okay so I guess you
said this Line's the best okay and we
have these very simple steps to get the
curve is one I'm on the balls of my
feet not the inst steps never go on the
InStep every time we have broken a foot
here and we
have It's a UK who could not get or did
not get to their ball of their foot they
tried to use the InStep so I think we've
had Taylor Sean and Ronan have all
broken their feet for the for the InStep
am I am I right or no okay he's not in
yes okay so uh it's and Margaret too
okay so what okay four times or you're
the fourth one four toes four toes Okay
so you can't you cannot take the force
of your body on your InStep which is why
there's no Sports where there's a secret
InStep technique there's not no
basketball right I'm going to do my
fakey on my InStep n it doesn't happen
there's no volleyball Spike from the
InStep there's you don't see it anywhere
it's biomechanically unsound to support
the weight of the body the ball of the
foot works okay so we're always on the
ball of the foot and to learn this this
we want to look at the shape so this
line is the line of attack uh my Center
gravity is going to be uh projected on
the line of attack okay and you have to
game the ultimate throwing pattern uh
because there's so much centrifugal
force and inertia not in the self
trining okay so what we're going to do
here is we're going to ignore what
happens to the feet CU you don't get to
choose what happens to the feet feet
anyways okay we really paying attention
to where do my hips go and where does my
head go or be my hips because that's the
center of gravity line of gravity so as
I do this on the line of attack I'm
going to go back bring my head off the
line of attack allow my hips to stay on
the line of
attack it looks like this
some common mistakes especially if
you're coming from fedorite stuff is
you'll let this turn in this knee will
turn in and when it turns in you have
less deviation off the line of attack
and you get really close to staying on
the line
attack okay so when you take that first
video and you're going to work through
the progressions make sure that you see
a 90 deviation in your head in relation
to the line of attack that should be a
minimum so I'm going out this
way all right we'll try that
one all right as if your response to
actually being thrown for real your UK
is going to they're going to have the
the bodily experience of get me the
out of this thing okay and that is why
Emi is part of the spiritual training
because you have to reconcile the fear
of injury the fear of death the
egocentricity that comes from your own
body facing harm okay um
so uh for example here we we don't rank
you if you can't reconcile the fear of
bodily harm you're low on our uh student
Senpai cohi hierarchy okay because
ultimately uh we're about right the
training is about self-release well You'
proven you can't get to the most basic
of self-release which is release of the
physical harm of the body okay there's
harder things to release right like the
attachment to pleasure uh the will to PO
like you got no shot okay uh if the body
is still with you to that
degree so you will watch how people will
try to regain control of their Center as
they try to disengage from the technique
and it is very very it's more common on
the back breakfall than the front
breakfall uh because there's more sense
of
vulnerability uh to falling backwards
than there is forward um which is why
you see like you know self-help groups
today will have you fall backwards and
you you get your trust in your team
building and all that okay uh
there's just more fear to Fallen
backwards um all right
so you have those progressions in the
other video and I just want to deal with
what's most common that's one of the
things that's most common and the first
sign of it is that they'll start to turn
that knee in uh cuz they want to lower
themselves more um but they won't be
able to in the technique now they can't
train cuz they can't receive the
technique uh I had one great story from
Chiba Sensei um where he actually left
our Ken chus class uh out the back door
so we didn't even know he left uh he
just left the mat and said if you cannot
receive the technique I cannot teach the
technique and then he just we was gone
and I think we were all waiting for him
to come back and finally someone went
and looked and he was gone he left the
dojo
okay so very very key if you cannot
receive the AR I cannot transmit the art
okay um the next part where you see a
breakdown is that and and is fear
related as they try to regain control of
their Center is they'll lose
relationship between the extremities of
the body um and so you what I mean by
that is as they're falling backwards
they kind of break
the posture that allows them to land
safely okay so you'll get things like
they fall loose like that okay uh that's
very
dangerous uh Adam you were doing that a
lot it's but it's very common you cannot
uh disengage your internal
organization uh when you take you KMI so
you have to maintain
organization uh for the internals
throughout the throughout the fall so
some drills that we do that is we
establish a relationship between the
head and foot if you maintain a
relationship between the head and foot
then you're likely to be organized
through the midsection and thereby
you're likely to uh land in a safer way
without spinal injury or organ damage
okay so one of the drills that we have
for that is where
I learned to tie together the foot and
the
head and we're coming around like this
it doesn't do me any good if I do this
drill like
this I lock my
body in my
organization and I do the
drill and Tra
sides so when the head goes down the
foot comes up and vice
versa the next structural relationship
that helps you keep safe for the impact
on the mat is the pelvic
tilt
um it tends to go out of the Tilt again
because of the
egocentricity which brings a loss of
awareness and uh it starts to add
towards the likelihood that you
segmented when you hit the mat uh
increasing the risk of spinal injury or
organ injury okay so when you're in that
final position you're not here but there
is a tilting up of your pelvis and the
drill we have for that one is this
drill so I'm not moving my hands and
feet I'm tilting my pelvis to do that
drill with this in mind you can see how
I'm doing that in the later progressions
as I drop
down I'm in that same tuck pelvis and
there's a relationship between my head
and foot from the very beginning so as I
go down my head goes back my leg will
extend
and you're in this
drill okay so we're going to work from a
standing progression down making sure we
have that pelvic tilt we're not going to
do those developmental drills where you
roll around in a circle or just flex
your pelvic tilt we're going to work one
of the
progressions okay try so we have those
progressions and we also have these kind
of body consciousness aware body
awareness drills the one where you go
around in a circle and the one where you
flex but you can see those that they're
not right as you're instructing on them
okay uh the next drill that we have that
we use is um to take
away or to acclimate the UK to find the
ultimate the final projection or sorry
progression in that sequence in that
previous video but not being in control
of when and at what rate of energy okay
uh so that's what we do now so he has to
get all the way to his final progression
and then we do something like this okay
maybe we have to come from the
side okay so to be clear at some point
he learned the progression where he
steps back and he goes
down okay cool I see a tilt I see a head
and foot relationship okay and his head
is 90 to the line of attack all right
uh we start having him bring it up to a
jog on his own this is the other
progression down he does the same thing
okay you can have a lot of people that
can do that one uh because they're in
control that is why okay so we start to
take some control away uh and at first
it doesn't matter the to what degree uh
but they don't know the when or or at
what rate and it could be very low and
you start to see technique fall apart so
all I do is push him into that
fall and he goes down and you just keep
doing that back and forth you
know and as you're getting it and he
gets there you you should be able to
start shoving really
hard he has to be able to keep the form
okay um anyone who breaks the structure
the necessary organization there you got
to come back to the earlier progressions
and get them to do that however you have
to be realistic that the art is
ultimately a spiritual art one that
requires the reconciliation of fear and
at a certain point there is no
biomechanical progression that's going
to solve that okay meaning some people
will just not you'll never be able to
shove them hard they're never going to
get past it it's not going to happen
okay don't mistake this fear oriented
drill with those biomechanical
progressions okay um the next one we
want to do because you won't ever get to
do this back breakfall like he just did
where your foot gets to step down uh I
mean that's like light training right
like we're not trying to throw you
that's how you get to do that um usually
we do that for the UK who can't
reconcile the fear we let them do that
so we throw them for that okay but you
might have noticed that uh he was able
to step back the force was uh singular
in its nature had a single line of
attack I'm not sending the three aspects
of posture in three different directions
okay and nor am I kicking out
deconstructing his basic support so we
want to have some more drills that help
someone get in the
ballpark okay of where we're ultimately
going um so the first drill is we'll
give him back control and we know that
his Center has to be forward so we'll
have him Bend his forward bring it bring
his Center forward and then on his own
he will find the back foot okay we going
do that again um because in the other
drills he's able to step back see his
Center doesn't go forward it goes down
and he goes on but now we want his
Center to go forward so he has to bring
his Center forward and then find the
back
foot and we have them do that until they
can get that uh
in this
drill um it allows the scaredy cat UK to
still have a lot of control find the
front foot and also uh decide whether
they want the foot to go first or the
hand to go first and they usually pick
the foot um so we're going to uh make
more extreme how much hips are forward
and he now cannot
step back into the front foot he has to
almost jump on it but it's that's a bad
understanding it's more like a cat when
you turn a cat upside down the cat will
find the floor um and have their foot
ready to go so this is more like a foot
finding drill okay so I will hold on to
him and
exaggerate how much his hips are going
to come forward so I'm holding him and
you really want their chest to be open
he gives me the weight he's not holding
himself I'm holding him and then he can
pick which side he wants to go to but on
the next rep he has to pick the other
one and you'll learn to find your foot
and find what we call your inside hand
okay and I just let go when I want he
has to find that foot I'm not sure he
found it on that one did
he I'll watch this time am Maya you come
hold it and I'm going to watch
him okay he's finding it okay let's do a
few and here's where that Contracting
Center comes into play because that's
what the cat would do is they going to
contract their Center to find their feet
so he's he is bowing his Center back
giving her the weight but when he
regains control of his body which will
be after the throwing Apex he's going to
contract his Center uh like that one
drill where you pull up the extremities
okay he will contract that Center and
that'll give him his back foot so here
we
go here you go and see they he he kind
of floated for a second there which is
what you want to see the more you
contract the center the more hang time
you get the more likely you can find
that front foot okay so we'll do it
again and likewise the more he bows and
gives his Center the more contraction he
has the more likely he can find that
foot but fear has to be reconciled to
give your Center to get a good
contraction you're you're going to hold
me get ready okay so I give everything
to her go and I don't want to do that
that would be incorrect there was no
contraction of my Center when I'm doing
that I give her
everything and I contract at the end so
watch how
low I
am but let me get there I'm way
here that would be
wrong hold on can you want me
T in this drill I I'll tell you when I'm
done talking okay I get as low as I
can and then he can let
go and I have to
contract then I have to
find my inside hand so I'm going to go
to the right and I have to get that
and find it all right here we
go first do what I did wait want you to
contract your way back
up you're going to
contract contract there you go and
again
pelvis that's better so that's what you
do we let
go okay let's try so do that first thing
wait I want you just to contract your
Center and come back
up
again so you're doing
crunches don't let
go so I'm here I'm not going to
go I trct the center I'm here
boom
boom do you see how my feet are
mobile
here Bo give your
Center then he lets
go kind a float for a second okay try it
again let's just do that drill
first give them your way
float find your feet okay
try you never put your weight on her
hands hang there hang there hang there
and then use that weight
better hang hang hang
hang
nope again hang and use the Hang to get
you up
nope switch
rolls
[Music]
good Kate go back to the next drill to
be in the next progression so you got to
find your foot you can't leave your feet
there and just find your
hand good you see you're going to float
for a while
good good all right switch
rolls okay so you can't leave your feet
there
can't leave your feet
contract you got to find your
foot got to find your
foot all right so you you you you would
work on that and you keep working on
that right and this is just a sign of uh
one's fear reconciliation and body
attachment okay but you can move on to
other things as you're training so as I
come around here I don't want to start
doing this kind of
stuff I can keep his hips he's he's
pushing for
prescription I find him I keep his hips
going
forward you can do the
technique with no
inry if your
UK cannot get it okay they're still
getting something they're still for
example what are they getting they're
not in
control um they feel a tiny bit of the
uh
try vectoring of the head the foot and
the center okay you kind add a little
more
mass as you work on this
thing so I entered
now and I kind of have the vector of the
x
pattern because now that I enter this
arm can more hit this way it can't
really hit that way with this one really
come back this way but once you bring
your Center in with the
EDI but you can see I have not taken out
his leg okay and the degree at which you
challenge the UK is going to be related
to how clean an X and how deep an X you
have okay so meaning uh if my UK this
can't do it then I could have entered
this way
that's a shallower less sharp X if my UK
can do it I can't
enter but I'm not on the right Vector I
didn't take out the leg okay and then
once your hook gets everything that's
where you take out the leg okay
um from the last
progression to when you take the leg out
there's no
biomechanical step to do it you just
have to have
already the internal organization of
your
body the physical coordination of the
pelvic contraction once you're out of
the throwing
Apex and then the fear
reconciliation that you're going to find
the mat on the end okay sometimes they
get their foot underneath them and
sometimes they don't okay it really has
to do with how sharply the nogget was
able to use their
xow okay there's no drill for that it's
a totally a spiritual step that you have
to make